you were having a hard time recruiting
people to sacramento
as your headquarters and then the world
went remote
during uh the pandemic and you had just
ramped up this whole
recruiting for sacramento kind of
process i remember how do you look at
the world now
since you were a company that really
coveted everybody being in the same
building and working together
and now you've been forced to be remote
how do you think about it today
are you going back to the offices or not
yeah good question
i think so grin will stay remote we'll
always have a headquarters in sacramento
but we leaned into remote and we're
going remote
we've already gone remote we're at 200
plus people now and more than half are
not in sacramento
and but i think like in an early stage
company like we have very clear product
market fit very predictable growth
big market opportunity but in an early
stage company
really what you're trying to do is
you're trying to find product market fit
and you're trying to establish the
culture
and i think the the process to find
product market fit is so messy
it's so collaborative with customers
prospects
teammates like you really need in-person
collaboration like you need to get on
the whiteboard i think and you need to
map out the problems and figure out the
solutions and so i think in an early
stage company being together is quite
important and in the same breath right
like we took a lot of time to really
establish the culture
what's the core purpose like why does
the organization exist what are our
values like
how do we think about the world and
because of that we had a really strong
hiring filter for the first
50 60 people because we're all in the
same office so i think because of those
two things because we have that nucleus
we've been able to make the transition
to remote
pretty seamlessly and i think but i
think as an early stage company
i would probably suggest still being in
in the same room
versus starting out remote that's just
my perspective
it's now at influencer marketing is now
three billion and it's
it's growing pretty significantly year
over year i think 30
40 what do you think the next milestones
are here what do you think is the big
the big next wave if you will or
momentum here that'll
and how far will it go so for me i think
there's a bunch of
market sizing stuff online like the way
i look at the market is really
bottoms up how many brands are there in
the world
and what's the scale and the second is i
think as this gets to maturity
like you look at a lot of the like high
growth direct brands like they're
spending
20 percent of their digital on this like
20 like really
yeah 15 20 of their total spend wow so
you start thinking like
what does 20 of advertising
look like in digital and right and so i
think i think the market sizing stuff is
pretty underestimated
from my view i think when you think
about where this is all going right
i'm constantly talking to marketers and
what i'm hearing from marketers is how
there's been this fundamental shift in
how people consume content
and like how people consume content has
changed in a pretty radical way
the way that kind of the market
describes that is this creator economy
like we're not living in a creator
economy what does that really mean i
think it means
that we used to tune into these legacy
channels and stations these companies
and you'd probably see this in your own
life you'd have these tv stations these
radio stations
it's not like that's totally gone but
what has really taken over our lives as
consumers is now we're tuning into
people
we're tuning into people on exactly and
i think so i think the future of this is
that
all the marketing that goes through
people historically
customer advocacy athlete marketing
right
influencer marketing to some degree
referral programs ambassador programs a
lot of stuff that i did at red bull and
that they do at nike and these really
kind of word of mouth driven
marketing tactics i think what you're
going to start to see is those
start to merge into one new discipline
the way that we talk about that
internally at grant is creator
management and i think the future is you
can see a future where every consumer
brand in the world
has a software solution to do creator
management at scale the same way every
b2b
company has a crm to do inside sales
like i think it's like that scale and
you're already seeing it pretty heavily
with the marrying of
affiliate marketing and influencer
marketing like they're so
similar and but also so different in
certain areas and so i think that trend
will continue
being driven by this idea that the way
the consumer engages with content is
totally different today
it's really interesting too because i
think a lot of the
people are very comfortable paying for
content
for streaming content disney plus
netflix
hulu without ads i pay for the nba
without
hbo max no ads i think there is a
movement when you're watching
television and narrative form that you
don't want advertising
it's just so annoying to deal with ads
when you're watching can you imagine
watching queen's gambit with ads
whereas listening to a podcast or a
youtube channel or tick tock
and having somebody in a tick tock or an
instagram feed talk about magic spoon
cereal
or have me read an ad for zendesk or
something it's like who cares it's not
like a big deal
you can fast forward if you don't like
the commercial you can keep streaming by
so i feel like those places are now
becoming ad free or the expectation is
less ads there which then makes it hard
to reach those customers am i right
that top tier customers are not
reachable
because they're paying for services
without ads
yeah i think like it's a great point i
think like have you ever thought about
that because i just had the realization
and when we were talking
about it oh yeah i've thought a lot
about it like the rise of ad blockers
like
people have this ad fatigue for sure
like
my view is that it's on the creator
to collaborate and do their best
to partner with brands that they
actually believe in i think
because it's such a better experience if
somebody introduces a product to you
that you already trust and follow
and that they actually like the product
than just being interrupted with an
advertisement whether it's on a show or
in the middle of your
social feed no matter how good the
targeting is you're still getting
interrupted like your experience is
getting interrupted
whereas if somebody is introducing it to
you in a way
is honest and real and relatable and you
get the sense that they actually believe
in it that's a much better
experience in my view so yeah i agree
with you i think the nature of
entertainment is just like and the
nature of media consumption has just
changed so rapidly
so you have both of those as factors
people are just swiping through tick
tock and instagram for an hour or two
hours a day maybe
more for younger people so that had to
that time had to come from somewhere
it came from network television or cable
television
and then you just think about the top
two streaming services
maybe the top three are ad-free
twilio is the cloud communication
platform used by
uber airbnb shopify and many others not
that you need any more names think about
that uber airbnb shopify it's basically
as good as it gets
you may have heard of them in the news
back in november of 2020 when they
announced their 3.2 billion
acquisition of segment one of the
world's leading customer data platforms
everybody knows segment if you're in the
industry twilio provides you the
building blocks to add messaging
voice and video in your web and mobile
applications
they are rooted in startup culture and
they are here to help you on that
journey
twilio gives you the power to build
communication apps easily
so you can spend more time focusing on
accounts your customers
engage and delight your users while
scaling globally
all from one api powered platform from
sms
to voice to whatsapp to email thanks to
that sendgrid
acquisition and founder ceo jeff lawson
has been
on this program multiple times i think
the last time was episode 967 back in
2019
let's book them again and here's what
you're going to get from twilio startup
program access to webinars made
exclusively for startups and
full support via the twilio startups
team a 500
getting started credit and 3 000 incen
grid credits
sign up now twilio startups.com twist
twilio twilio startups.com
twist so go get the bag right now 3 500
in credits waiting there for you to just
take them twilio startups.com
twist